the shimmer is a sort of phenomenon they
don't know what's happened to all of the
people who have gone in and kind of come
back
it is moving so quickly and soon it's
just gonna be devouring cities and
things and they just don't have any idea
what it is
I hate to know what's inside and she
decides to volunteer on the next mission
as we go in we start discovering that
things are just mutating more mutations
they're everywhere
sort of creepy things have to do they
understand they're no terrifying
it's really theory this used to be the
headquarters of the southern reach
before the shimmer swallowed it for
those that follow these the soldiers on
the last expedition they went crazy or
something in here kill them there was
some chilling
I definitely think annihilation is
something we haven't seen quite yet
something's come through the fence
through the fence I can't say anything I
neither can I
can you describe it's full no start from
the beginning what do you think I do
when you're away you think I'm out in
the garden pining looking at the sky why
are you I gotta leave a day early
[Music]
your husband's here let me see him
he's extremely ill you have to tell me
where he was what he was doing it was
his decision to go in
it's something they termed the shimmer
they've sent in drones in teams of
people but nothing comes back but
something has you're a biologist who
served in the military if I knew what
happened I could save his life
the boundary is getting bigger it's
expanding we're talking cities States
you need to know what's inside it's
beautiful
check this out it's like they're stuck
in a continuous mutation they understand
they're know sharks have teeth like that
not possible you can't cross very
different species
yes well soldiers on the last expedition
they went crazy or something here kill
them
something's come to the fence or the
fence we have to go back I can't go back
we can camp here tonight
it's destroying everything it's not
destroyed
it's making something new
[Music]
you
you